[Music]
[Music]
my name is come papa Shima and I was
born and raised in London there's always
been gang violence here but I've never
seen it worse than it is now it's a
brutal Street war that's destroying
lives every week so who are these gang
members and why do they choose this life
and if they do can they ever go back I
want to find out from the people
directly involved so I'm on my way to
meet a gang in Brixton they call
themselves 410 and are pretty well known
around here one of them was arrested for
a shooting just days before we were due
to meet after several attempts of trying
to meet them they finally reached out to
me and sent me your location ten minutes
out of the town centre they told me one
of their most active members will be
there to meet me
[Music]
my mom sold me the hard times surrounded
from young in it so we just know how to
see it everyday as a normal lifestyle so
I took her oath or that just I was stiff
it I kind of wanted to be a father
because it was the only life that was
shown to me that was glamorize to me
Anna so how deep would you say you are
in this skank laughs will you hundred
hundred hundred percent have you ever
seen someone be stabbed before so what
exactly is this that you're wearing
right now
oh I could see that you have like a few
marks and stuff here yeah sure has that
been like times when people have
attempted to try and kill you yeah to
see other people actually because when
you look at a lot more time musashi
effort again and that p4c trying that
hard why people try it that hard to kill
you um things such as gang affiliation
or things in the past you had to do in
our the cars like when you are in in a
gang certain times gonna have to do
certain things to other people you get
all fame on your name a little respect
on her name and certain people don't
wanna not talk to you certain way some
people wanna talk to a certain way you
got me cuz they're scared of who you
were before he become not a affiliated
and you have a stuff like obviously it's
easy way to make money there's ways to
make money when you involved easy ways
to make a good mom
this is a truck can get hurt you get
laughing you're hurting a family - it's
clear that JC thinks there's no way out
for him but at least he's still alive
there's been many casualties already
this year an average of three killings a
week and they didn't go unnoticed
watching Sky News at five o'clock the
headlines this evening the mother of a
teenage boy shot dead in London makes an
emotional appeal for an end to violence
in the capital the victim was an
up-and-coming rapper police are
investigating whether he was caught in a
gangland Feud Raheem Boston was 17 when
he was shot there by a rival gang in
South London on the day he was murdered
he was coaching football with family
friends safe homes Luis
just hours after he was dropped off
Saif's received a call I said what was
happening says Rahim so what about
ringing he's been shot and I was at come
on do you mean he's been shot and he was
that he's been shot he's dead I was like
how he was just with us yeah - awareness
there are no words that I can kind of
explain it was just this fall I had lost
my own son Rahim starred in dozens of
music videos with hundreds of thousands
of views making him a target for other
gangs the music essentially was a way
for him to express himself in a way that
you couldn't you know on a daily basis
in society and he'd been rejected by
pretty much every institution that he
went to you know from the age of 8 he
was a good a good kid I had his trust
from a young age and I think he was just
looking for that kind of role model kind
of father figure to to trust in and
confide in and have that support London
is different in so many ways to the rest
of the country Sky News has done
analysis of murder crimes throughout the
UK
everywhere our pots from London the
racial preference victims and murder
suspects is a simple reflection of the
racial mix in those areas but not in
London here gang violence has left its
mark in the last 18 months almost half
of murder victims and murder suspects in
the capital are young black men way out
of proportion of London's population so
can it really be the case that for a
large number of young black men living
in London it's kill or be killed
memorials like this one can be found all
over London mostly for young men who've
been killed on the streets and police
never seem to be too far away while
filming in Brixton we came across this
police call it a show of force they tell
us there's been a gang-related incident
[Music]
I find out it's a drive-by shooting no
one was killed this time but I want to
find out what it must be like for the
people living here two guys came from
off of the estate and my neighbors
couple of doors down they got off there
outside that there door I'm still shaken
up remember in it they actually got off
two guys one with a shotgun and one with
a pistol and basically stood outside
different door and fired and I'm couple
of doors down and it freaked this I mean
they are use at the end of day going to
school with weapons to protect
themselves or whatever at the end of the
day I've been told my kids grew up in
this sort of environment as much as I
try to keep them out of it but this for
them and you know and it's you don't
want at the end of day that and personal
experiences all those the people that
have been stabbed in American cars when
it's personal cause then it's like it
comes closer to home and for them it's
part and parcel of you growing up now
and for me it's horrendous defective you
can't actually sit outside in front
garden or walk up and down or go on a
bus and everything else for me it's a
different world shaman isn't an only one
here for straited oh the younger youths
them growing up chipping each other with
knives and all these things yeah now the
reason for it many
dunno why but they deny like they don't
the reason for it is a system
they it's their pleasure to run away a
baby father or a husband from the house
when they do that the kids grow up like
a fox no Road mother doesn't matter if
you're black or white it's beyond black
and white now after several shootings
and stabbings I didn't hear from the
gangs for a while but after a few weeks
I finally got in touch with someone he's
a young guy belong it's one of the most
feared gangs in London and he agreed to
meet me in his area I'm on my way to
meet the woola's ways
[Music]
believed to control much of the drug
supply in southeast London their
reputation is fierce
much of the violence of run here's link
to them
I'm taught to pick up a senior member of
the gang who's just got out of jail and
he said he would introduce me to his
friends tell us about your gang are they
powerful here you're popular they don't
you people oh wow they're all faces and
they're noble verified and today so
obviously we do offering and obviously I
take a living my face is pretty good oh
no and then anyone could walk around
people see my face
everyone knows who I am they see me they
know my name that you'll walk on bro and
how does that make you feel going on
ashy knowing that a lot of people know
who you are like you look what will
happen if you saw someone that one of
your ops right now OC love how she jump
back gang like super laughs like that's
the end of the situation in there was
also a reason they've obviously done
stuff to me or a couple of my people to
me cause be after the minute be honest
you must be a bit like fearful sometimes
when you're out there living faith
wolves he is paranoia at thinking who's
there who's there in that car over there
who's that
obviously he's just watching what's
going on
[Music]
as it was hard for us to get a good
opportunity left to be someone good to
be somewhat successful he came to us
easy he started this game and it was
that was like a game to us we started it
he had loads of money coming in nice
cars nice clothes nice kills he could be
whatever you want don't ever eat our
army even though we're out there 24/7
that was all way to make a living and a
living obviously this absolute path to
living could get shiny sir can you get
stopped at any second cuz these roads
it's not a safe roads it's cold you
should Kona yeah why why is that dude
what are you protecting yourself from
hey people are gonna kill me
there's some more protection to be
honest yeah role sense about that no you
got a knife on the street yeah and you
get into a beef with someone yeah yeah
gonna have a fist fight now it's 2018
Brock yeah they're gonna pull out a
weapon so are you yeah you're not I'm
saying some - I yeah
they don't you know fish fight him so
obviously a guy over there and because I
don't like him up for stabbing he's not
looking for actually as again he's a
family it's not the gang as a family all
in groups of boys he grew up on the same
estate we watched all that school
together if one of his gang members this
said to one of my gang members all of
his side of his gang I'll be after all
of you and all the bad guy will be after
you go because you disrespected one of
our family members do you think that the
me reason as to why they're getting into
this road life and they're getting
involved in oil dish crime is because
their background isn't the best some
people come from a background some
people choose something perfect
something you have to do people don't
have a choice obviously I know uh no
copper use they come from they come from
a good background enough
and obviously they said yeah are they
like a lifestyle cuz they know copper
meet she's done it they said here let me
join in they want to do after no kids
he's come from Chelsea everywhere good
night mom good night that but they've
chose to you some of us have to do it
some of us comes from the states from
get all places I know what you see
around when you look at your house is
you Shannon mushy corner self selling
job smoking jobs and so then you look at
them thinking you I think I want to be
that then one day do you think this life
is worth poor your mom through that yeah
she only worries if she actually knows
that you're in trouble
no I'm saying so you don't check through
your mom a night like that because you
don't want to worry her anyway yeah but
you make sure every day you always ring
or go on to your parents a lot of people
think gang violence is fueled by the
drug me but after speaking with the
Willis boys I have discovered is
actually more than that a lot of these
murders have been happiness simply
because someone has been disrespected
usually or social media the way that
young people feel validated through
likes to views you know and it's because
they have a lack of self-worth these
young people are looking at it as again
I know that there are scoreboards if you
kill certain people in a certain way
then you get a number of points he never
leader border Judah gangs even know what
this war is about these guns that no way
said by it's not about status it's all
about territory but its territory for
things that they don't even own they
don't own any property didn't own any
streets they're just doing things
because they think they have a protect
their area it doesn't make any sense
there's no evidence this gang was going
to end anytime soon
and the people affected the most are
desperate for a solution I believe that
it's a community problem and the
community has a Soviet so you know these
people you know in hours of the
Parliament politicians they don't
understand because they're not from
they don't live it they don't see it
even the gangs themselves don't see how
it will end
mr. Zhang useful opportunity but as a
part of portunity be there for us I
always wake up thinking wrong you don't
know what could happen today that I step
out
I could have to decide to someone also
someone could have to decide to me it's
the only life you know you have to just
keep doing it there's nothing else to do
in it the only thing for certain is that
if someone makes that decision to join a
gang it's going to be very difficult to
go back